[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live.
Hoje eu tenho uma presença aqui
ilustríssima, Dr. Rodrigo Vent, e nós
vamos falar sobre o protocolo Recode,
vamos falar sobre o congresso de
medicina integrativa que ocorrerá na
cidade do Porto, em Portugal. Já vamos
falar sobre isso. Então, queria dar
minhas boas-vindas a todos vocês. As
boas-vindas, Dr. Rodrigo Vent. E
lembre-se, pessoal, dá o like nesse
vídeo, ative o sininho para as
notificações, se inscreve no canal se
não tiver inscrito, compartilhe esse
vídeo nos seus stories se você tá
acompanhando através do Instagram. Essa
transmissão é simultânea no Instagram e
também no YouTube.
Bem, para quem não me conhece, eu sou
Dr. Alan Dutra e eu tenho várias
certificações aí na minha carreira como
médico urologista e na medicina
funcional. Eu tenho uma certificação
Recode, que é o reverse cognitive
decline, que é o assunto da live de
hoje. E eu também sou board certified
anti metabolic and functional medicine
pelo American Board of Anti-Aging and
Regenerative Medicine. E o Dr. Rodrigo
Ventin é um excelente dentista
biológico, o primeiro dentista biológico
certificado pela IAOMT no Brasil, que
International Academy of Oral Medicine
and Toxicology.
Então essa live vai ser sobre falar
sobre a reversão do déficit cognitivo,
falar para vocês que a doença de
Alzheimer tem como a gente tratar, tem
como a gente ajudar esses pacientes. E
também uma preparação pro Congresso
Internacional de Medicina Integrativa
que vai acontecer na cidade de Porto em
Portugal nos dias 5 e 6 de dezembro. E
nós vamos fazer aqui um apanhado de
todas as causas multifatoriais da doença
de Alzheimer, do dé cognitivo e fazer
uma conexão com a toxicidade bucal, com
as questões da boca que Dr. Rodrigo
Vendim que muito brilhantemente vai no
explicar e também no final nós faremos
então uma sessão de perguntas e
respostas. Muito bem, Dr. Rodrigo, muito
bem-vindo a essa live. É um grande
prazer tê-lo aqui comigo.
Meu prazer tá aqui de novo com você, com
toda essa sua audiência fiel. Nossa,
olha, tivemos juntos dando aula no
congresso de câncer e foi assim
impressionante a quantidade de pessoas
que vieram cumprimentar o Dr. Aan Dutra.
Então eu queria te dar os parabéns,
doutor, pelo trabalho incrível que você
tem feito com o seu canal de trazer
informação. Eu sei quanto que você
estuda, o quanto que você tá updated
para poder trazer para toda essa esses
milhares de seguidores aí. Então,
parabéns. Para mim é uma grande honra
estar aqui com você. Muito obrigado,
viu? Só para que eu agradeço.
Só para
A honra é minha
também tá aqui.
A honra é minha de tê-lo aqui.
Muito obrigado, viu, doutor? Eh, o Dr.
Alan, que me inspirou também a fazer o
curso do Recode e eu também sou o
primeiro dentista
Recode, Reverse Cognitive decline.
Então, ele trouxe, ele foi o primeiro a
a trazer, né, essa certificação pro
Brasil. E aí eu tive oportunidade, como
eu fiz a acreditação para ser biológico
dentist nos Estados Unidos para
International Academy of Medicine Tox
College. Daí me tornei fellow dessa
associação. E aí eles estavam falando,
fizeram um
uma associação com o programa do Record,
né? E eu participei dessa formação e
fico muito feliz, né, de ser então o
primeiro dentista recode e também a
fellow dessa associação.
Hoje a odontologia biológica ela ela
ela não é uma especialidade, né, doutor,
ela é uma filosofia.
E a gente atua nessa área, assim como
também na área integrativa, que não
existe especialidade,
mas sim de uma forma mais holística,
numa forma assim da gente enxergar o
paciente como um todo. E hoje a gente tá
muito feliz de estar aqui divulgando o
congresso que vai acontecer agora em
Portugal, né, que é o sétimo congresso
internacional
ah de medicina avançada que vai ser 5 e
5 e 6 de dezembro na cidade de Porto,
que eu já tive a oportunidade de
participar de algumas algumas vezes e é
o ano passado foi uma coisa incrível,
né, esse congresso organizado pela
sociedade Portuguesa de Medicina
Integrativa e pela mulher que faz
acontecer na Europa, né, que é a Dra.
Ana Moreira.
A Dra. Ana Moreira é uma médica
integrativa que atua em Porto e ela tem
organizado esses esses eventos com com
muito brilhantismo, né? E eu fico muito
contente de poder est coordenando uma
sala nesse nesse congresso e de poder tá
convidando grandes nomes, assim como o
Dra. Alandutra, né, a Fernanda Padovani,
a Maria Emília Gadelha, Dr. Elisete Cer,
Dr. Ícaro Alves, Dra. Vanessa Ribeiro,
Dr. André Contini,
o Afonso Salgado também vai tá por lá, o
Tom Tom nutricionista também vai est por
lá, Rodrigo Aub, entre outros grandes
nomes da medicina, odontologia,
enfermagem, em nutrição, né? Então é um
congresso extremamente eh
multidisciplinar. E é isso que a gente
quer mostrar, como esses grandes nomes
conseguem juntos, trabalhando juntos,
conseguem obter grandes resultados, né?
Então, muita gratidão aí por
por ajudar a divulgar esse grande
evento, mas vamos falar do que
interessa, né, Dr. Alan, sobre recod.
Esse vai ser o seu tema durante o
congresso, não vai ser? Sim, vai ser meu
tema durante o congresso. É um tema
essencial, muito importante, porque é a
aplicação de todos os princípios da
medicina com a visão funcional, a
medicina com a visão integrativa na
saúde holística do paciente, para que
além de melhorar a saúde geral, também
tenha a reversão do défic cognitivo.
Como é que começou essa história do
recode, que é uma sigla americana para
reverse cognitive decline? Foi o Dr.
Dale Bradson que implementou isso daí. E
qual que é a história do Dr. Dale
Bradson? Ele passou mais de 20 anos em
pesquisa básica de laboratório
procurando o que todo mundo estava
procurando na época, a chamada bala de
prata, que seria aquela molécula
maravilhosa que ia resolver a doença de
Alzheimer. Aquela molécula, se você
criasse uma droga que se ligasse a essa
esse receptor específico, você estaria
resolvendo a doença. Então ele ficou
estudando por mais de 20 anos mecanismos
moleculares da doença. Ele trabalhou
especificamente com o Nobel Stanley
Prusner, que é um laboratório lá de
pesquisa importante nos Estados Unidos,
publicou mais de 220 artigos científicos
na área. Ele trabalhou com modelo em
rato e modelo em mosca. E até que a sua
esposa, ele era casado, é casado até
hoje com a Dra. Eida Bredsen, que é uma
médica de família praticante da chamada
visão funcional. E ela um dia resolveu
cutucar ele. Dr. Deo, você não vai
encontrar uma droga única para trotar o
Alheim. Você precisa consertar o estilo
de vida do paciente. Ele não dava muita
bola para isso. Até que depois de muitos
anos batendo cabeça, tentando achar
aquela molécula maravilhosa, bala de
prata, não conseguia achar. Então, foi
essa mudança de paradigma. ele se tocou
que a doença era multifatorial e isso
levou ele a desenvolver o protocolo
recode depois de muita pesquisa em que
ele pôde identificar os 36 fatores que
contribuem pra doença. E tratando cada
um desses 36 fatores, que ele faz uma
analogia muito interessante que é como
se fosse um telhado com 36 furos. E a
partir do momento que você tapa a
maioria dos furos, você consegue começar
a frear e até reverter a doença. Então é
a diferença crítica entre as condutas
atuais de você tratar somente os
sintomas e retardar o avanço da doença e
tratar a causa raiz, que é muito mais
importante do que só mascarar os
sintomas. E por que que o modelo
ortodoxo falha? Porque a monoterapia
ela só aborda um aspecto. Geralmente os
remédios que a gente usa como
monoterapia é para aumentar o nível de
acetilcolina, neurotransmissor da
memória no cérebro. Só que isso, na
melhor das hipóteses, atrás a doença.
Então, nós temos que ter uma abordagem
multifatorial. Nós vamos falar dos seis
tipos de doença de Alzheimer aqui
durante essa live. entre esses tipos tem
a boca como também o mecanismo
fundamental na gênese da doença. Dr.
Rodrigo vai explicar muito bem para
vocês aí os fatores da boca que
contribuem para o desenvolvimento da
doença.
E nós temos uma estatística chocante que
os medicamentos, mesmo dos caríssimos,
tá, que lançaram os últimos anos, esses
aí de utilizam anticorpos monocolonais
para bloquear, né, a as proteínas
disformes do Alzheimer para bloquear o
betamiloide,
tem uma taxa de falha altíssima, pode
chegar até 90% de falha esses
medicamentos. Então, a gente tem que
abordar a causa, os 36 fatores
metabólicos que destróem os neurônios. E
existe uma janela de oportunidade que
você pode reverter a doença nos estágios
iniciais. Então, vou falar rapidamente
aqui dos seis tipos de Alzheimer e aí o
Dr. Rodrigo depois vai tecer as suas
considerações. O tipo um é o tipo
inflamatório, o tipo quente, que é uma
inflamação crônica que vai afetando os
neurônios. Isso tá muito associado a um
gene, a uma variação do apoe. Nós temos
o apoê 4, que é um dos que mais aumenta
o risco da doença. E as causas de
inflamação crônica. Vou falar várias
causas aqui no terreno do Dr. Rodrigo
que ele vai falar também se temos a
disbiose intestinal, nós temos várias
infecções crônicas por herpes, vírus e
outros tipos de bactérias, fungos
também. E a periodontite, o Dr. Rodrigo
vai falar daqui a pouco sobre a
periodontite como uma das causas pro
tipo um inflamatório. E aí nós temos
vários marcadores inflamatórios, exames
de sangue, por exemplo, proteína ser
reativa, citocinas inflamatórias, que a
gente pode est monitorando esses
pacientes para poder tá vendo o fator
inflamatório contribuindo. Lembrando que
geralmente os pacientes t três causas no
mínimo em conjunto. é multipatorial,
pode ter três, quatro ou cinco, mas
geralmente tem três ou mais. Então, Dr.
Rodrigo, pode falar um pouquinho sobre a
periodonto, uma porta de entrada para
esse tipo um inflamatório?
Posso? Vamos aproveitar. Então, ah, a
gente acredita,
nós acreditamos que quando a gente tem
as moléculas que vem dos
micronutrientes, que vão fazer os
neurotransmissores,
que vão compor os neurônios, né? Porque
os neurônios eles não aparecem, eles são
feitos e para isso eles precisam de
tijolinhos. Esses tijolinhos precisam
chegar até o nosso cérebro.
Então, vamos lá. Primeira coisa que
acaba impedindo que eles cheguem é a
microcirculação,
a micronutrição,
né? Os micronutrientes e a oxigenação,
assim como também toda a parte de
limpeza. Então, tudo isso é muito
importante para que quando chegue no
cérebro a gente tenha essa formação de
neurônios.
De uma forma simples, tudo que gera
processo inflamatório vai gerar
citocinas que vão gerar fatores de
defesa. Esses fatores de defesa, eles
vão ativar as nossas células,
principalmente as nossas células do
cérebro, e vão falar assim, ó, atenção,
vamos entrar no módulo de defesa. E esse
módulo de defesa vai ativar então
barreiras. Essas barreiras vão ser
colocadas ali no nosso cérebro, que são
as placas do betamiloide,
e vão impedir que as toxinas, bactérias,
vírus e fungos cheguem até o nosso
cérebro.
Porém, também vou impedir que a
microcirculação, micronutrição,
oxigenação e também a limpeza do nosso
terreno ali biológico e do nosso cérebro
aconteça.
Outra coisa, outra forma de defesa é que
a proteína tal, que Dr. Alan depois pode
até conversar, né, explicar,
eh, ela acaba ficando enfraquecida por
causa dessas citocinas.
e ela começa a descarrilhar, ela começa
a colabar, implodir, impedindo também
que essa micronutrição, microssação
acabe chegando. Então, a proteína tal
enfraquecida, assim como também as
placas betamide, vão levar
principalmente a a esse processo de
diminuição de cognição, demência,
Alzheimer, entre outras doenças
neurodegenerativas.
Tá faltando mais alguma coisa, doutora?
Não, a gente vai falar sobre os outros
tipos, né? Você já deu uma introdução aí
sobre a microcirculação, sobre o papel
das infecções da boca, né, dentro do
tipo inflamatório.
Vamos dar seguimento aqui. O tipo 1.5,
né, que o Dr. Dale Bre se caracterizou é
o tipo doce, né, entre aspas. Por quê?
Porque o excesso de açúcar no organismo
que não está sendo adequadamente
metabolizado,
gera uma disfunção energética no
cérebro. O neurônio tem sobra de açúcar
para queimar, mas não consegue queimar
esse açúcar. E isso então é o conhecido
como diabetes tipo 3 ou o tipo
glicoatrófico ou glicotóxico. Então o
açúcar literalmente gruda nas proteínas
cerebrais, provocando a glicação. É como
se fosse aquele leite condensado, né,
que a gente faz na cozinha. Você vai
mexendo o leite na temperatura,
aumentando no fogão junto com açúcar,
vai glicando, vai causando aquele leite
condensado. Isso acontece no cérebro
também.
E aí você tem essa glicação provocando
inflamação no cérebro e essa resistência
insulínica cerebral impedindo a entrada
de glicose no neurônio. Então isso é um
tipo que é dos mais comuns junto com o
tipo inflamatório que nós começamos aqui
a discorrer sobre ele. E o tipo dois é o
tipo atrófico, que é o cérebro faltando
nutrientes, é o cérebro precisando de
vários nutrientes que não estão chegando
lá. Então isso pode ser vitamina B12,
vitamina D, podem ser vários hormônios,
porque nós vamos falar sobre isso,
fatores tróficos como BDNF, NGF. Então
nós temos no cérebro 500 trilhões de
sinapses e que elas precisam de suporte
para se manter e muitas vezes nesse tipo
atrófico você não tem suporte. Então, é
muito importante
a gente ter essas causas bem examinadas,
bem pesquisadas, que pode ser vitamina D
baixa, vitamina B12 baixa, hormônios
baixos, BDNF, que é o brain derived
tropic factor reduzidos.
Então, eh, na falta desse nutriente, o
cérebro fica, eh, com falta de suporte.
O cérebro tem que escolher quais são as
sinapses que ele vai manter e quais são
as sinapses que ele vai desfazer. É como
se já tivesse uma casa, tá faltando
comida, tem cinco filhos, mas só tem
comida para quatro, né? Então acontece
isso e vai se desfazendo então as
conexões entre os neurônios. Então, pode
ser deficiência de várias vitaminas e
minerais, pode ser deficiência de
hormônio tiroidiano, pode ser
deficiência de estrogênio, pode ser
deficiência de testosterona, pode ser
deficiência de pregnenolona. E esse é um
tipo que responde mais lentamente ao
tratamento do que o tipo um, que é o
tipo inflamatório. E esse tipo também, o
tipo dois, ele também tá associado à
aquele gene apoe e4. Nós temos o tipo
três, que é o tipo tóxico. Então tem
muitas toxinas no meio ambiente. Rodrigo
vai falar também sobre mercúrio do
amalgma dentário. E essas toxinas
elas podem causar também o Alzheimer.
Então o Dr. Rodrigo vai falar sobre isso
daqui a pouco. Mas também temos as
micotoxinas do morfo em causas que t
filtração na parede, causas que t o
problema da parede cheio de umidade.
Você tem também os polentes orgânicos,
que são os derivados do petróleo,
tolueno, benzeno, poluição atmosférica.
E esse tipo tóxico é mais comum nos
portadores do apo e3, né? Então essa é
uma característica interessante. O apo4
é um grande fator de risco para o
Alzheimer, né? Mas no caso tipo três,
que é o tipo tóxico, o apoio TR é o que
tá mais associado, né? É um caso que não
é tão associado a parte familiar, mas
sim a parte de exposição. Então o tipo
três é mais comum em pessoas mais
jovens, na faixa de 40 a 60 anos de
idade. E geralmente tipo três não começa
com perda de memória, começa com
dificuldade em fazer cálculos
matemáticos na fala, na organização.
Dificuldade para calcular gorgeta, troco
do mercado, dificuldade para soletrar,
jogar alguns jogos de cartas como pôker.
E aí, Dr. Rodrigo, fala um pouquinho
sobre os metais na boca em relacionados
ao tipo tóxico, tipo três.
Então, vamos lá. O amálgama dental, ele
tem 50% de mercúrio. E esse mercúrio,
ele é extremamente tóxico, porque ele
adora a tubulina. A tubulina é quem faz
o arcaboço desse desse neurônio. Então
esse neurônio ele vem se formando. Você
tem a fibrila, que é por onde segue a
informação, e tem uma capa, né, que é a
tubulina.
Ele tem uma afinidade muito grande com
essa turbulina. Então ele vai e acaba
tirando essa turbulina, deixando esse
esse neurônio praticamente nu, né? E
então ele vai enfraquecer e vai
inutilizar. E o mercúrio, ele tem sido
utilizado durante mais de 200 anos em
restaurações e hoje cada vez mais se
prova através de eh ciência, através de
artigos, mostrando que o amalgama dental
ele não faz bem pra nossa saúde,
principalmente quando a gente pega uma
pessoa que tem ah, porque acontece, né,
Dra. falando. Ah, mas eu tenho amálgma
há 300 anos e nunca tive nenhum
problema. Ah, eu coloquei dentista, né?
Eu coloquei amálgama na minha vida
inteira e nunca tive problema.
Tudo bem, você deve ter um apoio
favorável, né? Agora, aqueles que têm um
apoio quatro, tem um apoio três, esse
pessoal, ele eles muita, muitas vezes
não podem nem sentir o cheiro quando
tem. A gente tem vários casos de pessoas
que tm ele na boca.
acaba tendo uma série de consequências.
Então, é muito importante a gente também
entender quem é, qual o tipo de apoio
que tem e o risco que essa pessoa tem
com esses metais tóxicos.
E o amalgma dental para que não não
cause mais mal pra pessoa ainda, ela
precisa ser removida de uma forma que
não contamine. E essa forma ela precisa
ser cuidada antes, porque quando a gente
toca com a broca no amalgama dental, a
gente vai fazer vibrar todo aquele
mercúrio que tá no nosso corpo. o
mercúrio que vem não só da restauração
de amalgama dental, mas que vem do da
alimentação dos peixes, né? peixes
grandes, principalmente como peixe
espada e o atum, que vem de diversas eh
vacinas como o etilcúrio, que é
utilizado, acredito que não nem se nem
sei se é mais utilizado, mas muitas das
vacinas foram utilizadas com etercúrio
e contaminaram muitas pessoas.
Ah, e esse mercúrio, quando a gente
coloca a broca no dente, através de um
processo chamado ressonância, ele vai
vibrar no nosso corpo e vai mobilizar. E
é nessa mobilização que a gente precisa
tomar cuidado, porque vai ter uma
sobrecarga na nossa corrente sanguínea,
uma sobrecarga que pode acabar
contaminando, né, eh, o nosso fígado,
nossos rins, tiroide, pode uma parte
também acabar metilando e passando pela
barreira encéfalo, barreira
emoencefálica
e pode acabar prejudicando, mas vai
prejudicar principalmente quem quem tem
esse esse apoio três, apoio quatro, é
que vai mais sentir. Então, existe o que
a gente chama de remoção, segura do
amalgama dental, que é remover de forma
segura para o paciente, para o dentista
e também para o meio ambiente, né? Quem
fala muito disso e tem um curso chamado
Smart, que é o Safe Amalgam Removal
Technique, que é ministrado pela
International Academy of Ormates in Top
School. Tem muita gente que acaba não
acreditando
nessa forma de remoção segura e a gente
respeita. Mas quem trabalha nesse ramo
sabe, né, do recode, sabe o quanto que é
importante isso para que a pessoa não
venha se contaminar e não piorar mais
ainda o seu o a sua condição, certo, Dr.
Alan?
Certíssimo.
Então, dando seguimento, né, aos tipos
de Alzheimer, nós temos tipo quatro,
vascular, que tá muito associado à
doença dos pequenos vasos cerebrais, que
também tá associado à doença
cardiovascular em geral, pessoas que têm
aí problemas na circulação.
E o vazamento vascular é uma das
primeiras mudanças que acontece a
Alzheimer. Quando eu peço, por exemplo,
um exame de imagem cerebral, uma
ressonância, é quase sempre 99,9% das
vezes vai ter microangiopatia
e gliose, que é justamente esse problema
de circulação na microcirculação
cerebral. E temos muitas pessoas que têm
pressão alta por muitos anos, muitas
vezes sem sintoma nenhum, porque as
pessoas pensam que pressão alta tem que
dar dor de cabeça, quando que a maioria
dos casos não dá dor de cabeça. Então
essa hipertensão silenciosa não
diagnosticada em muitas pessoas pode ir
destruindo os vasos cerebrais e isso vai
causando uma máculação cerebral e vai
privando os neurônios de oxigênio.
Existe também uma conexão forte aí com a
pneia do sono. Então, Dr. Rodrigo, ele
pode falar para nós sobre anatomia oral,
o que que tem a ver anatomia oral e das
vias aéreas com a pneia do sono, que
pode ser uma das causas mulfatoriais do
Alzheimer.
Vamos lá. Muito bem colocado, doutor.
Ah, se fala hoje muito do dessa
obstrução, né? é o airflow, como o ar
ele acaba entrando, sendo absorvido
pelos pulmões e sendo ah e levando
oxigênio até o nosso cérebro. E é uma
parte muito importante que a odontologia
vem ajudar bastante. Então, quando a
gente não tem esse espaço vazio da
língua, né, porque rangeu os dentes,
quebrou os dentes, tá com prótese e a
prótese tá desgastada, perdeu o osso,
fez com que diminuísse a dimensão
vertical, o espaço da língua fica eh
fica sendo uma coisa que interfere muito
no processo respiratório.
Então é necessário se devolver esse
espaço através de uma reabilitação
através de ortodontia,
né, ortopedia funcional dos maxilares,
para que a gente possa ter devolver essa
saturação de oxigênio.
Quando a gente tem o ronco e a pineia,
normalmente a gente conversa com o
nutricionista, conversa com o médico,
com os terapeutas, para que a gente
possa acertar a alimentação e reduzir o
o a gordura. Quando a gente faz isso, a
gente também diminui, né, que tem
adipostos na língua da gente, então a
gente também vai diminuir um pouco a
língua. A gente também
pode utilizar o laserbio e para
melhorar, mas se não tem se não consegue
grandes resultados com isso, uma outra
forma é de fazer um aparelhinho para que
faça a protusão da mandíbula, para que
evite que a língua quando a gente
relaxe, ela toque lá atrás e aí estimule
o o arco glossfaríngo, né, dizendo e
quando tem o toque da linha língua lá ou
de alimento, automaticamente ele vai
abrir a o faringe para que possa entrar
o alimento e vai bloquear a faringe por
onde entra o ar. Isso gera a sensação
de,
né, de sufocamento. Tudo isso acaba
ativando o nosso sistema de luta e fuga,
gerando aumento da da
aumento da pressão, aumento dos
hormônios que geram a lutuga, como
cortisol e adrenalina, mas
principalmente a dessatura e é isso que
leva também ao Alzheimer.
Perfeito. Ótima explicação.
Então, é importante também a gente falar
que existe também o tipo cinco, que na
minha prática é o menos comum, eh, que é
o tipo traumático. Geralmente são
pessoas que sofreram traumas cranianos
repetidos, jogador de futebol americano
nos Estados Unidos ou alguém que
trabalha na construição civil, talvez,
que bateu muito a cabeça.
Box,
box, bem lembrado, box, né? O pessoal
que pratica box.
Então essa cada pancada nessa cabeça vai
acumular um dano e esse dano pode ser
cumulativo
e gerar problemas no futuro. Também tem
o caso dos idosos que caem muito, né? Os
idosos que têm problema de locomoção,
que já estão com a marcha dificultada,
eles podem cair, ficar batendo cabeça
várias vezes. Esses traumas leves que
muitas vezes né, a pessoa nem desmaia,
nem necessita sempre fazer um exame de
imagem, eles são perigosos também. Então
é importante a gente ficar atento quanto
esse histórico de trauma cadaniano
repetido, que pode ser uma causa também.
E o ponto crítico que já falei, vou
repetir aqui, a maioria dos pacientes
tem uma combinação que vai de dois a
quatro tipos. Na média são três tipos.
Por isso que a monoterapia farmacológica
sempre falha, porque ela busca só uma
causa e quando são 36 causas dentro
desses seis eh tipos que nós conversamos
aqui. Então, por isso que nós precisamos
de uma abordagem multifatorial, precisa
entrar muitos profissionais de saúde,
precisa ter médico, precisa ter dentista
e precisamos trabalhar em conjunto para
reverter esses casos.
E cada tipo ou subtipo tem intervenções
específicas. Pode falar, Rodrigo.
Acho que vale salientar a importância da
nutricionista também, né?
Principalmente na na alimentação
para que possa tá orientando. E eu acho
que até valeria a pena falar sobre o
health coach, que seria uma pessoa que
iria acompanhar, porque esse tratamento
multidisciplinar
ele ele depende de várias coisas para
que a gente possa ter sucesso, né? E o
Dr. Alan, um dos médicos que mais tem
experiência no, vamos dizer assim, na
América Latina, com certeza, né? E com
certeza no Brasil, você e a Dra. Poliana
Castro, né? Eh,
é, eu fui o segundo médico certificado
pelo Rod América Latina e
Dra. Polian depois também fez a formação
para meu prazer, né? Porque a Dra.
Poliana é neurologista de formação.
Ah, que ótimo. E essa parte de,
vamos dizer assim,
de tá cuidando de uma forma
multidisciplinar é muito importante
também tá ajudando a pessoa a coordenar
todo esse tratamento, né? Então eu acho
que entra também coach, que ainda não é
muito desenvolvido aqui no Brasil,
mas que a gente sente a necessidade, nós
trabalhamos com essa parte de cognição
de de ajuda, de tá orientando e tá
acompanhando, né, Dr.? Você sente essa
essa?
Sem dúvida eu tenho um problema sério
com essa questão do coach, porque a
gente sabe que as formações de coaching
aqui no Brasil são muito focadas em
parte financeira, né? e não tem esta
visão de saúde, né? Então, as as pessoas
que fazem formação em coach geralmente
não se interessam muito por isso. Espero
que isso vai mudando com o tempo. Eu
hoje tenho uma pilha de um paciente que
atua como coach, que ela me ajuda aí nos
casos, mas existe também um problema que
muitas famílias hoje ainda não entendem
a importância do do coach, né? Porque
são muitas peças para você movimentar na
no ritmo de vida do paciente, da
família. O tratamento é muito completo e
por ser completo mexe com a vida inteira
da pessoa. Então é muito importante por
causa dos hábitos de vida que haja uma
pessoa que fica cobrando no bom sentido,
né? buscando aí eh ter esses contato
semanal para que a pessoa possa orientar
e tá acompanhando as dificuldades do dia
a dia. Então o coach é muito importante,
é uma pena que no Brasil está muito
pouco desenvolvido ainda,
ainda, né? Cabe a gente no futuro
ainda,
né?
Vamos falar então. Oi, pode falar.
Quem sabe no futuro você não monta um
curso
mesmo para ajudar, né? os casos, aliás,
o, vamos dizer assim, a pessoa quando tá
doente é muito mais complicado e
sensível e difícil de tratar quando você
trata na parte de prevenção, né, do Eu
acho que vale a pena est acompanhando,
principalmente para prevenir, ah,
começou a memória a ficar ruim, não vai
esperar ter um diagnóstico de Alzheimer
para poder então a prevenção é a parte
mais importante prevenir começou, ah, tô
começando a falhar. Vai procurar Dr.
Alan, né? Normalmente o Dr. faz o
tratamento no momento certo, indica aqui
a a parte odontológica também para que a
gente possa estar verificando, né? A
gente falou aqui da da gengiva, que
também tem o porfiro romana gengivales,
entre outras ameba gengivales também
estão relacionados, mas a gente tem
outros vários fatores, quem sabe a gente
consegue também falar aqui, né, canal,
cavitação óssea, eh o o vírus onde a
gente encontra ele na boca também, que é
da família do ERPS. Vamos voltar a falar
disso depois, mas só pra gente concluir
isso,
eu acho que falta e fica o convite aí
pro Dr. Alan Dutra fazer um curso,
principalmente para esse pessoal health
coach, principalmente as nutricionistas,
elas iriam ajudar bastante. Agora o tipo
de dieta que você recomenda, qual que é,
doutor?
Bem, a dieta que a gente recomenda é uma
dieta que seja cetogênica, mas é um tipo
de dieta cetogênica, que é uma dieta que
não existe essa prevalência, que nem o
pessoal pensa de ficar comendo produtos
de origem animal. Não é que é proibido
comer produtos de origem animal, mas
quando a gente fala dieta cetogênica, o
pessoal pensa automaticamente comer
bacon o dia inteiro, né? Algo assim, não
é? Isto é uma dieta que a gente chama de
ketoflex,
eh, keto de cetogênico, flex, porque é
flexitariana, significa que você pode
fazer tanto comendo produtos de origem
animal ou se você optar ser vegano
também é possível. E o jejum entra nessa
dieta como uma coisa muito importante
que você faz 3 horas de jejum antes de
dormir e se mantém entre 12 a 16 horas
de jejum desde o jantar até o dia
seguinte, né? Então, é uma dieta
extremamente importante que a gente vai
abordar daqui a pouco um pouco mais
sobre essa dieta. Mas antes de falar
dela com mais afinco, eu queria falar
sobre os pilares do recode. São sete
pilares, tá? Quais são esses? Otimização
metabólica. O primeiro pilar que é o
controle glicêmico rigoroso através do
jejum, através da dieta ketoflex, que
nós estamos começando a falar desse
assunto. O jejum intermitente de 12 a 16
horas.
E a nossa meta é deixar a glicose de
jejum entre 70 e 90 e a hemoglobina
glicada abaixo de 5,4%
com a insulina de jejum também abaixo de
10, idealmente por volta de 5 a se.
Então a última refeição, como eu falei,
3 horas antes de dormir. Já vamos falar
mais sobre a dieta. Vamos só falar dos
pilares, depois a gente vai pra dieta. O
pilar dois é a redução da inflamação,
que seria o quê? você priorizar a
conexão intestino cérebro e a conexão
boca cérebro, eliminando os alimentos
inflamatórios, especialmente açúcar,
doces, alimentos processados, refinados,
industrializados, glúten, laticínios,
as lectinas, muitos casos, isso aí tem
que ser visto caso a caso, mas as
lectinas que vem dos vegetais para
algumas pessoas pode ser problemático. e
utilizar vários
suplementos que vão ajudar a reduzir a
inflamação, como ômega-3 em dose
terapêutica, que pode ser de 2 a 4 g de
EPA com DHA, a curcumina, a bouzuélia
serrata, o resveratrol, tem uma lista
bem grande de antiflamatórios naturais,
tratar o intestino hiperpermeável.
Então é assim muito importante a gente
fazer a eliminação dos alimentos
inflamatórios, a repovoação desse
intestino com bactérias do bem,
bactérias boas,
repor também as enzimas digestivas
quando é necessário e reequilibrar todo
esse organismo. O pilar três é
otimização hormonal. Então você
verificar como é que está funcionando a
tireoide, verificar se o TSH, que é um
hormônio cerebral, né, que produzido na
hipófise, se ele tá alto, ele dá uma
pista pra gente de que o T4 livre ou T3
L podem estar abaixo. Então a gente tem
que otimizar a tireoide, dando os
nutrientes necessários para tireoide e
muitos casos também repondo o hormônio
tiroidiano se essa pessoa tiver com
hipotiroidismo. e também verificar os
hormônios ditos sexuais, que na verdade
são hormônios que atuam no corpo
inteiro. Então isso é um é um termo
inadequado, porque a testosterona tem
quatro mecanismos de ação diferente no
cérebro. Você tem o estradiol, que tem
ação cerebral. As mulheres quando entram
na menopausa e cai o estradiol, elas
começam a ter déficit cognitivo. Antes
da menopausa é difícil mulher ter
déficit cognitivo. A própria
progesterona, a pregnenolona, que também
tem ação cerebral, chama esses hormônios
de neuroesteroides, porque todos esses
hormônios têm ação no cérebro.
Uhum.
O cortisol, que tem que tá equilibrado,
nem muito alto, nem muito baixo, e o
DHEA também que é outro hormônio que tem
ação cerebral. Então esse é o pilar
três, otimização hormonal. O pilar
quatro são os nutrientes essenciais,
deixar a vitamina D no nível entre 60 e
80. Tem outros autores que falam de
outros números, mas eh tem vários
números diferentes aí, mas deixar nessa
faixa aí do normal superior, a vitamina
B12 também acima de 500 e também cuidar
pro ácido fólico na forma ativa, tá?
adequado no organismo. Se a pessoa tiver
mutação no GNMTHFR,
precisa ver isso e aumentar a dose do
metilfolato para essas pessoas que tem
mais dificuldade de metabolizar o ácido
fólico. Os níveis de zinco, os níveis de
selênio, os níveis de magnésio, porque o
magnésio é fundamental pro cérebro e
muitas vezes a gente tem que utilizar o
magnésio na forma de treonato, que vai
cruzar a barreira imatoencefálica de uma
maneira mais eficiente. Então é muito
importante a gente ver esses nutrientes
essenciais. E o pilar cinco é
desintoxicação. No caso do Dr. Rodrigo é
tirar o amálgama quando é necessário,
quando ele tá presente, através da
técnica segura de remoção da amálgama,
que tem toda aí uma um equipamento
necessário para nem intoxicar a pessoa,
nem a equipe que tá fazendo a remoção
desse amalgama dentário. O chumbo é
importante, o cádmio, o alumínio, os
poluentes orgânicos, tolueno, como eu
falei, o benzeno e outros derivados do
petróleo.
As micotoxinas que podem vir eh do mofo,
que é isso aí uma outra causa que é cada
vez mais valorizado. Eh, quando a pessoa
mora num ambiente mofado, essas toxinas
do mofo podem estar contribuindo pra
formação do défic cognitivo do
Alzheimer.
E essa a parte que a gente tem mais
dificuldade às vezes de fazer exames,
porque você tem que avaliar toxicidade
pro metal pesado, toxicidade pro lente
orgânico, toxicidade micotoxina. Aí não,
muitas vezes não basta só exame de
sangue, tem que fazer exame de urina
provocado, né, com teste de provocação
com o quel tem que ver se fazer de
cabelo, tem que fazer uma série de
avaliações.
E aí você pode utilizar várias maneiras
de fazer detox, né? Eh, uma delas é com
tauna de infravermelho. Aí tem o
protocolo, protocolo Hubert que utiliza
a vitamina B3 em altas doses e tem
também uma série de situações pra gente
aumentar o funcionamento dos órgãos
escritores para você ter essa eliminação
adequada. A hidratação é fundamental
nisso. O pilar seis é a qualidade do
sono. É importantíssimo ter 7 a 8 horas
de sono de alta qualidade com sono
profundo, porque as ondas lentas que
acontecem nesse sono profundo vai ser o
momento que o cérebro vai ativar o
sistema glinfático, que é o sistema de
expulsão dessas toxinas através desse
sono profundo. Então é muito importante
então tratar a pineia do sono, como o
Dr. Rodrigo explicou aí para nós. E
porque a pineia do sono é uma dos
mecanismos que vai destruir o cérebro
através da hipóxia noturna repetida.
E muitos casos a gente tem que entrar
com suplementos para ajudar nesse sono,
que pode ser 5 HTP, pode ser melatonina,
pode ser inozitol, pode ser o próprio
magnésio, pode ser uma série de outros
aí que t uma ação muito importante
dentro da higiene do sono, que também é
importante você tá no ambiente escuro,
com escuridão adequada, que tem uma
temperatura boa para você não ficar
incomodado com temperatura inadequada,
nem frio demais, nem quente demais, e
tirar as telas acesas, né, tela de
televisão, de celular, uma hora antes de
dormir. O pilar 7, a estimulação
cognitiva e o exercício
eh a físico também. Então, é importante
você fazer tanto o aeróbico quanto o
anaeróbico. O aeróbico vai aumentar o
BDNF e o treino de força vai aumentar
vários hormônios, entre eles a
testosterona e a irina, vai preservar a
massa muscular e vai também preservar os
hormônios. É o mínimo de exercício, tem
que fazer 150 minutos por semana,
exercícios moderados e intensos, além da
parte de treinamento cerebral, são os
desafios cognitivos diários que essa
pessoa tem que estar fazendo para poder
ela tá aprendendo coisas novas
constantemente, tá estimulando o seu
cérebro, né? Então, falando, pode falar,
pode falar.
É, só para complementar, uma coisa que
eu gosto de falar pros meus pacientes
quando explico isso é que o nosso
sangue, né, ele tem que tá circulando,
então ele tá limpando o nosso terreno
biológico, tá levando oxigênio, tá
levando nutrientes, tá levando micro eh
nutrientes para que possa estar fazendo
os neurotransmissores, fazendo novas
conexões cerebrais. E quando ele começa
a ficar intoxicado, quando ele fica
parado, tudo isso deixa de acontecer.
Então, o fazer o coração bater como se
fosse ligar a bomba da piscina para
fazer a água circular pelo filtro. Quais
são os nossos filtros principais? Rins e
fígado, né?
Então, quando o sangue passa, ele vai
ser muito mais eh limpo e tira as
toxicidades, tira também tudo aquilo que
tá fazendo mal pro sangue e facilita
todo esse processo.
Faz sentido, doutoran?
Total. Então, a pressão quando você faz
exercício de perna, né, que é muito
falado na no recode, na minha opinião,
você tá forçando o coração a aumentar a
pressão para que possa chegar a
micronutrientes e a limpeza em lugares
onde tem uma maior dificuldade.
Maravilha. Vamos falar então da dieta,
porque a dieta é o maior desafio do dia
a dia no consultório. Por quê? As
pessoas estão habituadas a comer
farinácios, açúcares, né? Existe uma
predileção muito grande da sociedade em
comer esses alimentos processados,
refinados, industrializados com alto
teor de carboidratos. E como nós
falamos, um dos mecanismos principais da
doença de alzâmica, o tipo 1.5, é o
excesso de açúcar glicando o cérebro,
inflamando o cérebro. Então é muito
importante a gente mudar a dieta desses
pacientes, mesmo os que não tm
diagnóstico, só aquela pessoa que tá
começando a ter alguma queda cognitiva
na prevenção da doença e mudar essa
alimentação. Então essa dieta
quentoflex, eu comecei a falar sobre
ela, mas eu queria explicar um pouco
melhor agora, que que é? É uma dieta que
induz o organismo a usar a gordura como
uma das principais fontes de energia.
Quando você baixa o consumo de
carboidratos, de modo geral, o organismo
vai buscar novas fontes de energia.
Então, o que acontece? O fígado, ele
pega a gordura que está depositada nos
adipostos, nas células de gordura e da
pele ou até mesmo outro depósito de
gordura e vai queimar esses
triglicerídios que estão nessa gordura e
transformar em glicerolem e ácidos
grassos.
Esse glicerol, esse ácido gráico também
são fontes de energia, mas além deles
serem fontes primárias de energia,
acontece um outro processo que é a
formação de corpos cetônicos no fígado.
Esses corpos cetônicos vão pro cérebro e
vão pro coração. Que acontece? É como se
você fosse queimar a glicose,
vamos fazer uma analogia aqui, fosse
queimar carvão ou ou queimar algum
combustível fósforo. Na hora que você
queima a glicose, forma muito resíduo,
que são os radicais livres. né? Enquanto
que você queima gás natural, por
exemplo, você praticamente não faz
fumaça. Então essa que é a diferença.
Quando você queima glicose, tem muito
resíduo. Quando você queima os copos
teetônicos, esse resíduo já não
acontece. Então o cérebro que tá com
essa resistência insulínica esse
diabetes tipo três, que tem glicose
punível, mas ele não consegue captar
essa glicose por resistência insulínica,
ele utiliza os corpos cetônicos
novamente, são derivados da gordura para
a fonte de energia e é uma fonte de
energia limpa que não forma os resíduos
que a glicose forma. Então o cérebro da
pessoa que está insetose fica mais
ativo, fica mais alerta, a pessoa fica
mais inteligente, ela fica mais eh
rápida no raciocínio.
Então, para que aconteça essa cetose, é
por isso que a dieta chama ketoflex,
porque é uma dieta que você aumenta as
suas calorias da pr de gordura em torno
de 60% das suas calorias e baixa as
calorias do carboidrato para em torno de
20% até menos do que isso. Tem pessoas
que entram em cetose com 50 g por dia de
carboidrato, outras com 100 e outras tem
que restringir para 20 ou menos gidrato
por dia. Aí para chegar nesse ponto,
você vai comer gordura de qualidade,
óleo de coco, azeite de oliva. Você vai
utilizar as gorduras das castanhas noves
e amêndoas. Você vai utilizar
também ah de algumas gorduras saturadas.
Eu não tô te ouvindo, Rodrigo. Acho que
você deixou o microfone
abacate.
Abacate, né? Importante também como
fonte de gordura saudável. Então você
aumenta essas fontes de gordura
saudável. Lógico, nós estamos falando
aqui, não de utilizar eh óleos de
semente que são excessivamente ricos em
ômega-6, não estamos falando que usar
óleo de soja, milho, canola geração.
Estamos falando de utilizar outras
gorduras que são mais saudáveis. E
também não adianta você ficar utilizando
gordura hidrogenada ou gordura trans,
essas gorduras intereserificadas,
gorduras artificiais que fazem mal pra
saúde. São falando de gorduras
específicas que fazem bem pra saúde.
Então, com o aumento desse consumo de
gordura e cortando os carboidratos, você
vai induzir a cetose e essa cetose vai
ajudar a recuperar a cognição, né? Aí a
gente tira também os alimentos
inflamatórios
que na visão, né, seria o leite
derivado, né, que eles têm um problema
da caseína que vira que vira
betaomorfina.
Você tem aí também o glúten que vira
glúteomorfina.
Então você tira esses elementos
inflamatórios e existe essa orientação
das pessoas que gostam de eh ingerir
leite a derivado, que utilizem
esporadicamente o leite do tipo caseina
2 A2, né, que não é 100% maravilhoso,
digamos assim, mas que é bem menos
inflamatório do que o tipo eh comum aí,
né, caso na um. Então, a dieta é
basicamente isso, né? A gente pode est
eh fazendo alguns ajustes. Tem pessoas
que são veganas que não vão querer
ingerir produtos de origem animal. Pode
fazer sim, do mesmo jeito, essa dieta
ketoflex não tem obrigação nenhuma de
comer gordura de origem animal. E também
importante que a pessoa troque os doces,
por exemplo, cacau ou chocolate amargo
com os mínimos de ingredientes
possíveis, né? eh para poder evitar
estar ingerindo açúcar ou ingerindo
outros elementos inflamatórios.
E as frutas também tem que utilizar as
frutas que que não são ricas em frutose,
né? Então você vai usar fruta vermelha
que são altamente ricas em
antioxidantes, né? Como morango, como
cranberry, como blueberry, né? Mirtilo.
Você vai utilizar
então essas frutas, como no caso nossa
berry nacional, que é o açaí.
E você vai cortar as frutas que são
excessivamente doces, especialmente os
sucos de frutas. Quer acrescentar alguma
coisa, Rodrigo?
Quero. O açaí nosso, ele é cheio de
açúcar, não é? Não,
não. Você tá falando do açaí que o
pessoal conhece, que é aquele xarope,
né?
O pessoal faz e com açúcar. Mas o açaí
mesmo ele não é um um uma fruta
riquíssima em açúcar, né? Ela é porque a
gente utiliza o xarope, né? Que já é
industrializado.
Mas esse aí não pode, né?
Esse não pode. Esse xarope de açaí não
pode de jeito nenhum. Eu tô falando o
açaí, o pó do açaí mesmo do parar, né?
Isso. Isso.
Nossa. Aqui é cheio de açúcar. Então, só
deixar bem claro aí pro pessoal.
É, mas não é o açúcar, tá? Do próprio
açaí, é o, é o açúcar que eles
introduzem, eles introduzem depois, né?
É.
Ó, eu queria assim eh acrescentar a
importância da gente remover os focos
inflamatórios
no intestino e na boca. Então, o que
acontece? Toda vez que a gente tem focos
inflamatórios,
as citocinas, quimioas, TNF alfa,
interferon, etc., que vão sinalizar pro
nosso cérebro dizendo, estamos em
guerra, atenção, eles vão iniciar um
processo de defesa. E é esse processo de
defesa que a longo prazo vai nos
prejudicar.
São várias as formas que o corpo acaba
se defendendo e cada uma vai acabar
prejudicando de uma forma, como eu
falei, né, o acúmulo de placas betamide,
o enfraquecimento da proteína tal, mas
você tem também a a vasoconstricção que
vai diminuir no cérebro a via de acesso
dos alimentos e oxigenação e a limpeza
lá no cérebro. Você tem também o que eu
mais gosto, que é o aumento da da
viscosidade do sangue. Então,
principalmente a a o IL, né, e seis, ele
vai acabar diminuindo, acabar aumentando
a viscosidade que vai deixar o sangue
mais aglomerado. Então, todos esses
fatores inflamatórios vão gerar esse
essas formas de defesa que a longo prazo
vão interferir na microsituação e na
limpeza. E quando o sangue tá
aglomerado, ele acaba diminuindo a
oxigenação e a célps de energia. E aí
ela começa a obter energia através da
via anaeróbica, que vai provocar o ácido
lático, que vai acabar eh deixando o
nosso corpo mais e mais ácido. E quando
a gente tá ácido, o que mais se
prolifera são fungos e também células
células eh
nossa, tumorosas.
Uhum.
Certo, então, aonde que a gente tem
fatores inflamatórios
na gengiva e na parte periodontal, que é
ao redor do dente. A gente também tem
nos canais, principalmente nos canais
acessórios, colaterais, secundários, que
a gente tem dificuldade em limpar, a
própria literatura mostra que a gente
não consegue limpar 100% dos canais, né?
Tem uma parte que o corpo da gente
consegue encapsular, mas uma parte que
ele acaba deixando essas células eh
esses processos aumentarem. Quem que tá
ao redor do dente? Principalmente
segundo a literatura, o SS tem vários
citomal vírus que são primos do ERPS, da
família do EPS. que são todos ali da
família do ES vivida e que vão acabar,
né, causando alteração genética,
alteração do RNA e do DNA e estão
ligados a um monte de câncer, doenças
como eh síndrome de Jorgen, lupus
eritematoso,
artrite reumatoide, né, a entre outras
várias doenças. O outro lugar que a
gente também encontra desses fatores que
vão contribuir com o Alzheimer são nas
cavitações ósseas. Então, cavitação
óssea nada mais era do que um buraco,
uma caverna que se forma no nosso osso
por diversos fatores. E nesse lugar vai
acabar nascendo um soldado nosso chamado
CCL5 RS, que tem sido muito estudado
pelo professor Leckner na Alemanha e ele
demonstra que ele tá ligado em mais de
3.900 artigos referentes a Alzheimer.
Claro que também tem uma vasto número em
processos alérgicos, revisões de câncer,
a artrite reumatoide. Então isso também
vai acabar gerando a eh
esses fatores, né, essa essa citocina
vai acabar aumentando o índice de
câncer. E é um trabalho que também eu
vou est mostrando agora no congresso,
terceiro e terceiro congresso mundial
que vai acontecer no Rio de Janeiro. Eu
vou est falando sobre um trabalho que
nós fizemos aqui na 25 odontologia que
mostra que as cavitações óseas quando a
gente remove melhora toda essa
micirculação porque a gente remove essa
citocina que gera esse processo de
defesa que gera uma dificuldade para
chegar a toxina, a bactéria, o vírus e o
fungo até nosso cérebro. Mas ela também
dificulta de chegar o oxigênio, a
microcirculação, a micronutrição e
também a limpeza do terreno biológico.
Acho que era isso que eu queria tá
complementando. Além
ótima
do do fújo, né?
Ótimas. Você quer falar um pouquinho
sobre correntes galvânicas também?
Ah, corrente galvânica, a diferença de
potencial elétrica, né, ocasionada por
um metal diferente do outro.
Ele gera
que a gente chama de corrente galvânica.
O maior exemplo que a gente tem de
corrente galvânica é a pilha. Então, a
pilha você coloca materiais de
diferentes potenciais elétricos que
ficam se equilibrando, né? Eles ficam
trocando elétrons para se equilibrar até
quando a pilha acaba. Então você tem no
amgoma dental o mercúrio, o estanho, a
prata, o cobre, o zinco que fica
trocando com o ouro, com o o
níquelocromo, com o titânio. Isso tudo
acaba gerando uma corrente galvânica. E
essa corrente galvânica, ela pode acabar
nos nos prejudicando de várias formas.
Então, pode aumentar a salivação, pode
acabar causando maior sensibilidade
dentinária, pode causar mais
irritabilidade,
insônia,
uma série de consequências sistêmicas,
né?
Uma coisa que eu acho que é importante
também a gente ir abrindo o campo de
entendimento das pessoas é que existe
uma conexão elétrica, né, chamada
bioeletricidade, que é como o cérebro se
comunica com cada célula do corpo.
Então, existe essa informação que vai
passando tanto do cérebro para os
órgãos, como dos órgãos e das células
para o cérebro. Então é como se fosse o
master, né? Ele recebe informação, ele
processa e manda informação. Tanto a
corrente galvânica como qualquer tipo de
processo inflamatório crônico,
degenerativo podem acabar interferindo
no processo dessa informação. E quando a
gente tem interferência, né, desses
desse dessas vias rápidas que são os
meridianos, né, que a gente tá todo
ligado, né, ela não dá pra gente separar
a boca.
do ombro do dos órgãos, tá tudo
ligadinho através de de células que
formaram a desde a concepção houve uma
série de mitoses, né, de de meios e isso
tudo foi gerando uma conexão. essa
conexão quando tem esse essa diferença
de potencial elétrica, ela acaba
interferindo nesse processo e o órgão
acaba também causando eh tendo uma
dificuldade em entender e diminui a sua
eficiência, como também a sua
inteligência para paraa luta. Então, tem
essa parte que tá cada vez mais bem
estudada pela terapia neural, tá mais
bem estudada pela própria acupuntura que
tá aí há quase 5.000 anos, né?
Eh,
e o Vol, que é o cara que trouxe isso
pro mundo, ele pegou uma corrente
elétrica de 6 V, que são, né, quatro
pilhas, e colocou lá no ponto do pé
ligado ao meridiano, por exemplo, do
fígado. Ele falou: "Aonde será que essa
corrente eh vai acabar aparecendo?"
E ele verificou.
Rodrigo, você tá, você subiu da tela.
Voltou. Voltou. Sim.
Aí ele verificou que essa corrente
elétrica aparecia no canino. Ele falou:
"Ah, que legal, tem uma fibra ótica
aqui". Da mesma forma que o computador
nosso aqui tá tá transformando o nosso
áudio e vídeo em informação também essa
a essa informação era transformada
através dos neurotransmissores em
corrente elétrica e essa corrente
elétrica mandava informação pro nosso
corpo todo. Então trabalho super
incrível que tá sendo cada dia mais
divulgado, né? eh, levando informação
pro nosso corpo todo.
Maravilha. Então, voltando a assunto,
quando você tem um caso, então, de
alguém com défic cognitivo
ou até mesmo com um quadro de Alzheimer
já diagnosticado, é muito importante
fazer uma avaliação então simultânea,
tanto médica quanto odontológica. E a
gente chama isso de cognoscopia. Que que
é cognoscopia? São todas as avaliações
que nós fazemos para checar os fatores
de risco para que estejam contribuindo
para a peda cognitiva.
Isso inclui vários exames físicos,
exames de laboratório, avaliação
odontológica sistêmica, olhar pro
paciente como um todo. Então é
importante a gente identificar esses
tipos de Alzheimer que nós falamos no
começo da live através dos exames
laboratoriais
e fazer a remoção das toxinas, sejam
metais bucais, sejam metais que essa
pessoa teve contato ao longo da vida,
através da ingestão, da respiração, da
pele. Também se a gente identificar as
microtoxinas, as toxinas dos fungos,
fazer a remoção dessas toxinas, reduzir
inflamação através da dietaflex
e também através de exercício físico e
também através de vários nutrientes
específicos e suplementos específicos,
fazer a otimização nutricional e
hormonal. E é muito importante a gente
fazer tudo isso em conjunto para que
essa pessoa possa ter os melhores
resultados possíveis da estabilização e
depois reversão da doença. Então, quais
são os exames essenciais que as pessoas
devem fazer nesses casos, tá? Tem alguns
exames que a gente tem que chamar
atenção aqui, que não são os exames de
rotina. Por exemplo, é o caso da
homocisteína. O cisteína é um marcador
misto. Ele tanto marca inflamação como
ele marca também metilação. Eu não vou
tentar explicar o que é metilação. Basta
vocês saberem que metilação é um
processo fisiológico importante para
regular o DNA. Vou falar dessa forma. É
mais do que isso, mas como é um assunto
mais complicado, eu vou eh me abster de
entrar em detalhes. Mas essa
homocisteína,
esse marcador, ele vai dizer tanto
quanto está a inflamação quanto está a
metilação. Então, ideal que a mena
esteja abaixo de 10, em torno de seis a
sete e a gente para corrigir esse
marcador, muitas vezes tem que entrar
com vitaminas no complexo B, tem que
entrar com na que é a nestilcisteína,
tem que entrar com colina, tem que
entrar com creatina, tem vários
elementos que ajudam, a própria ômega-3
também ajuda. e fazer então os testes
metais pesados, seja pelo sangue, seja
pela urina provocado, e fazer o detox
desses metais pesados quando necessário,
verificar as frações do colesterol, se
você tiver condição de fazer um exame
mais avançado de lipidograma, que não só
vê o HDL, o LDL, o VLDL e o triglicides,
mas também vê as frações de LDL, que tem
um LDL fofinho e grande, que é uma bola
de praia. Esse LDL forfin grande, ele
não entra na parede da artéria para
causar aterosclerose, inflamação,
entupia artéria. E existe o LDL bolinha
de good, que é pequeno e denso. Esse LDL
de bolinha de good é o que é o
problemático, esse que pode causar danos
nas artérias, inclusive na
microcirculação cerebral. Então é
importante, quando for possível você
fazer essa avaliação do tamanho de
partícula de LDL. Se não for possível,
pelo menos, fazer a avaliação do Aolipo
Proteína 1 e da A polipo proteína B, a
relação entre os dois tem que tá eh no
máximo 0,7. Se passar de 0,7 já é um
fator de risco mais aumentado. Então
também manter a a glicemia, como eu
falei, abaixo de 90, manter insulina de
jejum abaixo de 10, manter a vitamina D
nos níveis ideais, manter o B12 níveis
ideais, manter os marcadores
inflamatórios baixinhos, da protecia ser
reativa abaixo de um, em torno de 0,5.
Eh, se for possível fazer exame genético
para identificar se você tem uma ou duas
cópias do AP4. uma ou duas cópies do
APE3, que são os alelos de risco na
genética. Tem o Apoc, tem o GAB, tem
outros genes, mas eu vou entrar em
detalhes para não complicar demais e
fazer a avaliação dos hormônios
completos, como hormônios tirodianos,
hormônios sexuais, hormônios adrenais. E
se você puder também marcar os exames de
teleucina 6, se for disponível na sua
cidade, ou exima do exame de BDNF
também, se você tiver disponível, são
exames mais raros de de conseguir fazer
a avaliação odontológica completa com
uma panorâmica digital. Em alguns casos
aí, Dr. Rodrigo pode falar, pode ser
indicado fazer a tomografia conibin de
feixe cônico, que é para avaliar esses
dentes, se tem foco dentário, se tem
cavitações, que são importantes focos
infecciosos que você comentou aí que
podem estar interferindo com a saúde
mental e também a o teste de
compatibilidade de materiais que você
faz aí na na clínica, né, Dr. Rodrigo,
quando você precisa fazer uma
restauração dentária, pode falar um
pouquinho sobre isso aí.
É só para complementar, Alan, a
homocisteína ela também aumenta quando
você tem problema perodontal. A cisteína
sim, porque ela é marcador inflamatório,
né? Ela qualquer inflamação ela ela
sobe,
né? Você tem vários eh problemas na boca
que vão fazer com que aumente o PCR
também. Então, remover os fatores
inflamatórios do intestino e da boca é
super importante para isso. E a gente
realmente acaba personalizando
os materiais, individualizando desde o
que se utiliza como resina, anestésico,
quantidade, a gente personaliza a dose
eh através da sinestesologia aplicada,
que ela é comprovada cientificamente,
né? eh, precisa fazer isso não, mas
quando a gente faz se torna muito mais
assertivo no tratamento do paciente, né?
Então, a gente utiliza esse teste
muscular que acaba ah trazendo pra gente
uma série de informações
individualizando isso. Doutora Alan,
nossa, que aula incrível, hein, a sua.
Parabéns. Sempre gosto muito de suas
aulas porque elas
não, mas eu que tô aprendendo muita
coisa com você aqui, ué, escutando você
falando.
Muito obrigado. Eu eu só queria eu não
sei se o nosso tempo, se a gente tem
mais tempo aí.
É, o Instagram tem um limite tempo, né?
É verdade.
Então eu só queria aqui eh aproveitar
para falar, olha, amanhã vamos ter
também uma live com a Dra. Fernanda
Padovani, que vai est falando sobre a
saúde da mulher acima de 40 anos, que
também vai ser super bacana. A gente
também ainda tem nessa a Dra. a Ana
Moreira, presidente do Congresso, né?
Ela ela tá sendo uma super parceira com
o Brasil, então ela
estendeu o convite a todos os
brasileiros a participarem
de forma sem custo lá desse congresso,
viu, Dra.
Então, é por isso que a gente tá também
aqui honrando ela e divulgando o
congresso dela para agradecer, né, tanto
essa sétima oportunidade desse congresso
tão incrível, mas também por estarem
participando. E eu queria também
convidar a todos os médicos,
nutricionistas, dentistas, enfermeiras,
ah, terapeutas que queiram apresentar o
seu trabalho,
eh, vai ter a parte de pôster, de
apresentação através de pôster, que as
inscrições estão abertas até dia 1eo de
outubro somente. Então, se você quiser
participar desse grande evento é só
novembro, né,
no Congresso, tá? Me parece que para
quem vai apresentar aí teria a adesão
para poder estar participando, mas para
quem só quer assistir é cortesia. Queria
também dizer que grandes nomes da da do
nosso Brasil vão estar lá, como Dra.
Alandutra, Dra. Fernanda Padovani, Maria
Emília Gadélia, Dra.
Cfer, que foi minha madrinha que me
trouxe para essa mundo da saúde
integrativa, né, Dr. Ícaro Alves, que é
nosso grande amigo, Dra. Vanessa
Ribeiro, enfermeira André Contini,
grande amigo dentista, Afonso Salgado,
fisioterapeuta que um um grande gênio,
estudou em Harvard e vai trazer uma
série de novidades. Tom Tom,
nutricionista, que fala muito sobre
biohacking,
né? o Rodrigo Ayúb, entre outros muito
nomes, né, da medicina odontologia, da
saúde integrativa de uma forma geral.
Então, queria só aproveitar e fazer esse
convite para as pessoas participarem,
fazerem a sua adesão para apresentar
seus trabalhos.
Só um detalhe, Rodrigo, você falou até
primeiro de outubro, se quiser primeiro
de novembro, né?
Novembro. Novembro, é,
desculpa, primeiro de novembro. Isso.
Então, temos mais praticamente
meio mês aí pro pessoal entrar em
contato e fazer a sua adesão. E se você
quer participar, aproveita, né, já
verifica logo e já vamos nos ver lá,
tomar um vinho do Porto juntos depois
também, né, Dr.?
Com certeza. Vai ser uma maravilha.
Bem, então já atingimos mais de uma hora
de live, já tem muito assunto que a
gente abordou aqui. Acredito que vocês
vão ter que assistir a live mais vezes
com calma para est absorvendo todo esse
conhecimento, porque foi muito muito
densa, com muito conhecimento essa live.
Ah, tem algumas perguntas aqui, acho que
pode responder umas duas, três perguntas
para encerrar. Que que você acha,
Rodrigo?
Vamos, vamos sim.
Vamos ver aqui as mais antigas.
Alguém tá comentando sobre esse exame
aqui? Eh, exame oftalmológico OTC. O
médico me mostrou os microasos mais
estreitos que saem do globo ocular para
o cérebro e que pode reduzir. Na
verdade, existe sim alguns exames, você
pode fazer oculares para ver tanto a
circulação quanto ver as condições da
retina, que pode ser uma janela pro
cérebro. Aí você vai ter uma noção de
como é que esse cérebro está. Porque a
retina é um pedaço do cérebro. Então, se
existe dano a essa retina, existe grande
chance que tem dano ao cérebro. Sim.
Então, sim, existe esses exames oculares
que podem ajudar a você fazer um
diagnóstico mais precoce da doença.
Ah, é em torno de 50 eh 500 trilhões de
sinaptees. Sim, ô Gian, só confirmando
aí que você falou.
Ã,
fui trocar as obturações. Me disseram só
se fosse o último caso, porque
geralmente são profundas.
e pode precisar fazer canal. Quer fazer
uma observação sobre isso?
Quero eh, na verdade existe uma parte,
eu sempre
antes de conhecer a saúde integrativa,
né, e fazer o curso lá da Contumbrilda
nosso querido amigo Braguini, eu
realmente acreditava que o amgama dental
era o melhor material e ele durava
bastante e ele não liberava mercúrio.
Foi quando o Bragini, no curso de
pós-graduação da Quantumville, ele
começou a mostrar uma série de artigos
de manifesto da International Academy of
Oral Medicine Toxicology, assim como tem
em vídeos que aí me fizeram realmente
quebrar o meu paradigma e acreditar
naquilo que eu tava fazendo não era mais
o melhor pro meu paciente. foi quando eu
realmente troquei, né, comecei a pensar,
a considerar na restauração de mercúrio
como sendo tóxica para o nosso cérebro e
pro nosso corpo e não simplesmente como
sendo benéfica para o nosso dente.
Então, quando você começa a expandir a
sua consciência e o seu conhecimento,
você muitas vezes também vai mudar de
opinião como eu mudei. Agora tem
trabalhos que dizem que o amgoma dental
não libera mercúrio, não faz mal à saúde
e tem vários outros que falam que sim.
Então, depende de você, daquilo que você
acredita, né? Eh, eu realmente não, eu
realmente acreditava naquele momento lá
atrás, quando eu ainda dava aula de
amalgental, que eu estava fazendo melhor
pelos meus pacientes. Até quando
professor Braguin me abriu os olhos e me
mostrou que eu não estava fazendo bem
sistemicamente para o meu paciente.
poderia até naquele momento pensar que
odontologicamente,
apesar que já existem estudos que
mostram que o homma dental ele pode
acabar expandindo e causando
microtrincas,
né, entre outras coisas. Ah, mas naquele
momento eu acreditava que que era o
melhor. Hoje eu já não acredito mais.
Hoje eu tenho certeza que a restauração
de amágama dental ela
ao longo prazo é extremamente
prejudicial à saúde, principalmente
naqueles que têm o apoio quatro e o
apoio três, como foi discutido aqui na
aula.
Sim. É, mas aí eu acho que ele tá
querendo colocar essa questão aí de na
remoção do amalgama a correr esse risco
de virar um canal. Como é que você
avalia isso?
Sim, toda a restauração
eh profunda pode acabar virando um
canal, né? Então, mais uma vez, qual que
é o grande segredo, a grande sacada?
Cuidar da saúde bucal, visitar o
dentista a cada 6 meses e não só quando
tem dor, né? A gente precisa entender
que precisamos limpar a boca da mesma
forma que a gente toma banho. Então,
precisa ter não nada de dormir sem
escovar os dentes, precisa passar o fio
dental, precisa cuidar da alimentação,
precisa fazer uma suplementação com
vitamina A, D, E, K2, né? a K2 que vai
falar: "Olha, vamos depositar no dente,
no osso." Então, quando a gente tem
care, a gente precisa entender porque
que tem a carne e não simplesmente só lá
tapa buraco, senão pode acabar
acontecendo novamente. Então, a
prevenção é muito importante, mas ela é
muito ampla, ela vai desde hábitos de
comportamentos em novos hábitos, como
escovar o dente e passar o fio dental,
como também a parte de alimentação, o
tipo de alimento que fica mais tempo na
boca. com açúcar, como um brigadeiro,
tá? É muito pior como, por exemplo, um
suco. Então, a gente precisa entender
como que cada alimento pode acabar nos
prejudicando e tentar trocando os
hábitos alimentares, trabalhando a
prevenção.
A gente tem que também pensar na análise
do risco da carne. Então, eh, saliva tá
funcionando ou não? Tem saliva ou não,
né? Ela tá funcionando para alcalinizar
ou não? tem muitos treptocólicos mutans,
mastigo direitinho, eh,
tenho tenho hábitos saudáveis,
tô tendo suplementação, tudo isso é
muito importante. Então, a melhor forma
é prevenir. Depois que teve o buraco,
sim, existe o risco da problema de
canal, tá? Então vamos lá de novo
prevenir, principalmente pros seus
filhos, para quem ainda não teve, para
aqueles que tiveram a carne profunda, eu
ainda acho que manter a restauração de
amágama dental na boca, produzindo
mercúrio, principalmente para quem é
apoio quatro e três, pode ser muito mais
prejudicial do que realmente remover e
acabar tendo o problema de canal. É em
todo mundo que dá problema de canal, não
existem várias dicas para fazer essa
remoção. Primeiro, uma broca nova, tem
que tá bem eh bem refrigerado. Tem uma
técnica especial que você faz ao redor
da restauração e tenta crivar para
diminuir a quantidade de vibração, de
aquecimento do mercúrio e
consequentemente também aquecimento da
dentina. Você tem o ozônio que você tem
o ozônio que vai bioestimular
a essa dentina, vai esterilizar essa
dentina. Você tem a o laser de herbia,
você tem o próprio laser de baixa
potência que pode melhorar, você tem o
ômega-3 que vai melhorar essa
microcirculação.
Tem que trabalhar os fatores
inflamatórios para que o sangue possa
est levando mais oxigênio, mais
fibroblastos. né, mais células de defesa
para que possa estar regenerando. Então
você tem várias coisas que você pode
estar melhorando para evitar esse
processo de canal, mas na minha opinião
é menos prejudicial do que manter o
mercúrio a longo prazo, principalmente
se for um apoio três, apoio 4.
A Lua tá fazendo essa observação, Dr.
Rodrigo 25, que é é a minha referência
aqui em São Paulo, mas eu acredito que
outros estados e no interior pode ser
mais difícil mesmo. Mas aí também você
pode se deslocar até São Paulo. Rodrigo
pode te ajudar nesse caso aí na remoção
segura dos amálgamas, né? A equipe do
Rodrigo. Ã, eu acho que já tá bom, né?
Deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma pergunta
aqui.
Tô perguntando sobre estatinas, que é um
assunto bem assim polêmico, né? Porque
tem estudo, Rodrigo, falando que
estatina protege contra défic cognitivo
e tem outros estudos falando que
estatina piora o défic cognitivo. Eu
acho que pela lógica, pela fisiologia,
faz muito mais sentido a estatina fazer
mal do que fazer bem para essa parte
cognitiva, né?
Na verdade,
diminui a quantidade de colesterol que
vão fazer as novas conexões cerebrais,
né?
Primeiro que o colesterol é matériapra
do organismo, né? Para fazer baend de
merina, para fazer membrana neuronal.
Segundo,
quando você baixa demais o colesterol,
que os protocolos hoje de cardiologia
prezam por uma redução excessiva do
colesterol, acontece justamente essa
falta de matériapra pro cérebro. Então o
que eu faço hoje no consultório com
muito sucesso, sabe o que que é?
associar vários elementos naturais que
vão equilibrar as gorduras do sangue e
doses mínimas de estatina, porque é
comprovado que dose baixinha de estatina
pode ter efeito antiinflamatório.
Interessante. Então essa junção de doses
baixinhas de estatina, eu uso mais a
rosovastatina com, por exemplo, extrato
de bergamota, com berberina de alta
absorção, com ômega-3, eh, com
predominância de época, por exemplo,
você modula as gorduras de maneira que
você continua tendo matériapra, no
colesterol, que é um lípide, não é uma
gordura, mas tá lá no meio das gorduras
para o cérebro e sem você e gerar o
problema do LDLX mais que é a origem do
problema da aterosc esclerosea, né?
Então essa que é a minha visão sobre
esse esse assunto hoje em dia. Ã,
eu acho que tá bom, né? Ah, eh, você
quer falar rapidinho sobre o fluor?
Isso é ass interessante,
bem polêmico, né? Eh, eu também,
eu no passado eu utilizava muito fluor,
sabe, ela? E o Fluor realmente melhorava
bastante a sensibilidade.
Mas quando eu fiz a formação lá no
Estados Unidos, eu comecei a enxergar
artigos que eu não não chegavam na minha
mão aqui. Então, só o manifesto da
International Academy of Medicine Tox
College, ele traz mais de 400 artigos.
Agora, tem gente que diz que não tem
literatura e tem gente que diz que tem
literatura. Então eu sugiro das pessoas
irem buscar, né, e
esse assunto que é tão polêmico, então
vamos buscar. Aí OMT tem um manifesto
que traz tudo isso mostrando vários
desses eh centenas desses artigos. E aí
aquela pessoa tem que tirar sua
conclusão. Ah, mas o Mercúrio é o
amálgama dental não libera. Vai procurar
os artigos. Procura também o manifesto
da International Academy, daomt.com.
Procura lá manifesto
eh contra os amálgas entis e aí vai
encontrar os artigos. leia e se
posicione. Ah, não, não faz mal, não faz
bem paraa minha saúde, não faz bem pra
saúde do meu filho. Ah, não tem problema
nenhum, não. E aí você vai, você mesmo
chegando à suas conclusões, né? A minha
conclusão é que tanto o fluor como
também a o amalgama dental, como também
asinas com bisfenol,
para mim não servem, pra minha clínica
não servem. Agora, mais uma vez, cada
dentista tem a sua visão, estuda, faz os
seus cursos e que busque os melhores
artigos para se posicionar naquilo que
ele realmente acredita, né, como eu faço
aqui com os meus pacientes.
Perfeito. Então vamos encerrar que já
estamos quase 1 hora e meia de live.
Queria agradecer novamente a presença do
Dr. Rodrigo 25 aqui no canal. Já já
fizemos várias lives juntos, sessão mais
uma, mas para divulgar esse evento tão
importante aí do congresso de Medicina
Integrativa Internacional lá na cidade
de Porto, que vou ter maior prazer de
estar participando esse ano. Para mim,
para mim é um prazer e uma honra estar
participando e realmente vocês
acompanharem a live amanhã com amanhã,
né, a live com a Padovani,
Fernanda Padovani. Isso vai falar sobre
da mulher acima de 40 anos. Vai ser
incrível também.
Maravilha. E para quem
o Dr. Alan é super famoso na internet,
né? Mas para quem não o conhece, qual
que é o Dr. Alan?
O meu @draalaindutra,
tanto no Instagram, quanto no YouTube,
quanto no Twitter, apesar que o, aliás,
se chama X hoje em dia, né? Apesar que
eu nunca tô lá, eu não entro no Twitter,
mas é sempre @dralaindutra.
E tá, e as suas redes, Dr. Rodrigo? Eh,
Dr. Rodrigo 25, que é 25 italiano, né?
Então, também
vai ser um prazer poder tá tendo vocês
aí com essas informações que a gente vem
trazendo cada vez mais nas nossas lives,
nos nossos estudos, na nossa experiência
de trabalhar na saúde integrativa de uma
forma multidisciplinar, onde a gente vê
melhores resultados e principalmente
mais longevos. Certo, Dra. Alan?
Certíssimo? Então, agradeço todos vocês
que puderem participar ao vivo.
Lembrando que os vídeos sempre ficam
gravados. Então, se você quiser rever
algum assunto que nós discutimos aqui,
vê com calma, não entendeu primeira vez,
assista novamente, divulga o link dessa
live paraos seus amigos e familiares,
ajude a espalhar a palavra, o bem, né,
pros seus amigos, pra gente poder ajudar
cada vez mais pessoas, principalmente
para aqueles que estão começando a
esquecer as coisas, porque é melhor
trabalhar na prevenção do que depois na
cura.
A curativa é mais difícil, é mais cara,
demora mais tempo. A prevenção mais
gostosa, mais rápida e mais econômica.
Com certeza. Muito bem dito isso daí.
Abraço a todos. Até a próxima. Um beijo
no coração.
Obrigado. Gratidão a todos. Até logo.